vaches maman tu vois beaucoup de café
quand même j'ai entendu dire que c'était
cancérigènes t'as vu ça où toi il ya des
études scientifiques qui montrent sa
attend le café un bon goût de cancer
attend 11 raisons pour lesquelles vous
devriez boire du café tous les jours en
tout cas c'est mauvais pour la santé
l'europe met en garde contre l'abus de
café oui mais trois cafés bio par jour
c'est bon pour la santé
non en fait le café c'est le prochain
produit cancérigène sur le radar de l'
oms le café réduit les risques de cancer
en tout cas il ya des raisons de s'en
méfier finalement virgules ce serait bon
pour la santé qui veut du vin
[Musique]
c'est sûr que si on se base sur les
articles de presse pour se faire une
idée sur des sujets de ce genre on a
rapidement une vision qui ressemble plus
aux idées reçues plutôt qu'aux réelle
connaissance scientifique mais se baser
directement sur les articles
scientifiques
c'est difficile quand on connaît pas
trop c'est souvent compliqué à lire en
vérité ça s'adresse pas vraiment aux
simples citoyens comme moi qui connais
rien au sujet l'auteur c'est une
chercheuse ou un chercheur ultra
spécialisée dans un domaine spécifique
elle s'adresse à ses collègues qui font
le même métier qu'elle met pourtant il
m'arrive de vouloir chercher une étude
scientifique ne serait ce que pour
vérifier que la conclusion correspondent
au moins un peu aux affirmations
sensationnel que j'ai lu dans la presse
parce que parfois les journalistes
s'emballe un peu et l'opinion sur les
réseaux sociaux s'emballe encore plus
l'idéal serait que tout le monde puisse
vérifier les sources bien sûr mais je
sais que l'on peut pas faire ça il faut
comprendre un petit peu l'anglais il
faut quelques notions de base en
statistiques pour interpréter les
résultats il faut savoir comment trouver
ses études parce que le mécanisme des
publications c'est pas simple et ensuite
il faut savoir comment interpréter ces
résultats c'est pas une mais ça
s'apprend c'est enseigner à ceux qui
sont destinés à devenir chercheur mais
moi je ne suis pas chercheurs c'est
difficile pour moi de savoir seulement
où chercher
[Musique]
demo alerte suis toujours en train de
faire des recherches sur le café comment
est ce que moi je pourrais avoir accès
aux études scientifiques à parce que
t'es pas dans une université ses rangs
oui mais c'est vrai que quand tu es dans
une université l'université elle va
payer pour que tous ces chercheurs aient
accès à un ensemble de revues
scientifiques et c'est ça qui est
complètement absurde parce que les
chargeurs y paye pour publier dans les
revues scientifiques dont qui paye en
fonction du nombre de pages de l'article
du nombre de figures qu'il ya dans
l'article de 600 couleurs pas et en plus
universités derrière elle adore re payer
des abonnements a servi à l'eau ouais
et donc quand t'es pas dans une
université tu veux quand même avoir
accès aux revues scientifiques
donc tu va d'abord chercher ton article
dans un moteur de recherche qui va
recenser les revues scientifiques et les
articles scientifiques donc genre je
pars à google scholar mais d'où open
édition en shs après tu vas pouvoir voir
déjà s'il est en open access c'est à
dire si en accès libre
donc il ya des chercheurs qui payent
pour que leurs articles soient publiés
libres de droits ce serait l'idéal pour
moi voilà donc ça ça existe a aussi des
sites qui recense uniquement tous les
articles qui sont libres donc ta arxiv
par exemple il ya à l' achat elle qui va
aussi recenser les mémoires l'élite est
extra et du coup une fois que tu as
trouvé ton article
si jamais il est peint en open access ce
qui est sous le choc ça arrive mais dans
ce cas là tu as toujours le nom de
l'auteur tu peux contacter par mail tu
peut le contacter par richard gates par
exemple qui est un site sur lequel tu
peux carrément demandé est-ce que je
peux avoir le pdf est pas mal non oui et
je vous aime les contacts et sur twitter
il ya un hashtag heineken has been fc
même assez connu pour sa est en général
pas les chercheurs ils sont contents que
tu parles de leurs articles que tu lises
leurs articles et donc à aucun aucune
raison qu'ils te réponde pas
généralement faire ça tout arrive alan
simon journal est sérieux il y a un lien
direct dans l'article vers l'étude en
question ou au moins à la fin une
bibliographie utilisable avec le titre
planer et l'auteur s'il n'y a rien moi
j'ai haussé les épaules et je passe mon
chemin
le café et ils cancérigènes s'il n'y a
pas de preuves il n'y a pas de raison de
le croire mais les études scientifiques
peuvent-elles être fausse il y a
régulièrement des études scientifiques
qui cherchent à mesurer la proportion
des études scientifiques qui pourrait
être fausse et lorsqu'on cherche à
reproduire à l'identique certaines
études que l'on trouvait convaincante
les résultats ne sont pas toujours au
rendez vous certaines disciplines font
en ce moment face à une crise de la
reproductibilité c'est-à-dire cup
quand on essaye le même protocole on ne
trouve pas toujours le même résultat
je vais essayer de faire une petite
liste des différents cas de figure à
garder en tête pour y voir plus clair
déjà il y a les cas d'erreur dû à une
mauvaise manip une étourderie de
l'incompétence et scientifiques sont des
êtres humains pas des superhéros
ensuite il y à ces cas de fraude
scientifique ça c'est plus grave
parfois c'est pour avoir des résultats
intéressants parce que pour un chercheur
la quantité de publication est un
critère pour l'avancement de sa carrière
les laboratoires sont bien au courant de
l'importance de lutter contre ça parfois
c'est parce que le chercheur a été payée
par un lobby
c'est pour cette raison que les conflits
d'intérêts sont très encadrés ces cas là
sont souvent décelé quelques temps après
la publication et l'étude est alors
retiré
parfois même les diplômes de doctorat
sont attribués de façon assez
complaisante
si vous êtes une célébrité médiatique
mannequin et astrologue votre thèse
incompréhensible a plus de chances
d'être retenu que si vous n'étiez
personne et ça marche aussi si vous êtes
un animateur de télévision
et puis j'ai vite de m'emballer face à
un résultat inédit la moitié des études
scientifiques
relayé par les médias seront réfuté un
jour la science ça prend du temps
si la découverte est toute récente
peut-être pas la peine d'en faire tout
un plat à la moindre annonce mais au
final sur un temps long la méthode
scientifique reste la meilleure méthode
que l'on est
les chercheurs sont les premiers à
s'indigner de ces cas là et je les
comprends parce que ça entache
réellement la valeur de leurs titres de
docteur dans l'opinion publique pour
repérer les revues complaisante qui
publie un truc plus en fonction du buzz
plutôt que du sérieux méthodologique il
y a les canulars scientifique
ça consiste à écrire un article bidon
avec une méthodologie foireuse qui
flatte la ligne éditoriale de la revue
mais qui ne respectent clairement pas
les critères que l'on peut attendre de
la science par exemple avec des phrases
qui n'ont aucun sens du jargon inutile
une conclusion qui ne correspond même
pas aux données et de soumettre aux
revues scientifiques du domaine
juste pour voir si les comités de
lecture sont vigilants et si l'éditeur
accepte de le publier l'exemple le plus
connu est celui de alan sokal qui a
proposé un article complètement
imbitable qui fut acceptée à la
publication dans une revue de sciences
sociales portées sur le relativisme qui
l'y a régulièrement des canulars qui met
à jour des terribles parfois rigolote et
mais toujours instructives parfois c'est
dur d déterminer si l'objectif du canard
est vraiment de déceler les dérives ou
juste une tentative pour discréditer
tout une discipline que l'on n'aime pas
l'an dernier la sphère du canular sur
les grilles vente si tu dises a fait
couler beaucoup d'encre dans la presse
trois chercheurs décident de proposer
aux revues scientifiques
une vingtaine de fausses d'études pour
essayer des pieds il avait ciblé
exclusivement des études sur les
stéréotypes sur le genre sur les
mouvements féministes car c'est un sujet
très sensible
plusieurs études ont été publiées mais
dans les sciences sociales
les enjeux ne sont pas uniquement
scientifiques les objectifs politiques
des auteurs du canular
donc aussi à prendre en compte et enfin
et surtout il y à lesquin de faux
positifs une étude scientifique a même
pas besoin d'être vraiment fosse pour ne
pas être reproductible
ça peut simplement être un cas où on a
juste eu de la chance avec les
échantillons si j'ai dix ont une
centaine de personnes volontaires et que
je demande à la moitié d'entre eux de
boire beaucoup de café et aux autres de
ne pas boire de café et que je surveille
leur état de santé sur des années
parfois c'est ceux du premier groupe qui
en moyenne seront plus malades parfois
c'est ceux du deuxième groupe
c'est aléatoire parce qu'il ya plein
d'autres facteurs inconnus qui compte
les virus les gènes la chance pour
s'assurer que ça vient bien du café les
scientifiques calcul en priorité les
chances que l'on avait d'observer ce
résultat si le café n'avait aucun effet
ce chiffre là on l'appelle la valeur p
si il y à moins de 5% de chances que ce
soit juste dû au hasard
on conclura que ce n'est pas juste bleus
hasard on dira que l'étude est
significative mais ça veut dire aussi
que si tout se passe bien sans erreur
sans fraude ni corruption et que le café
n'a aucun effet alors 5% des études sont
juste des faux positifs
du coup s'il existe des centaines
d'études sur un sujet il y aura toujours
un certain nombre d'études qui prouve
que le phénomène en question existent
mais cette valeur de significativité est
souvent mal comprise
les statisticiens n'arrête pas de mettre
en garde les chercheurs contre ce genre
de mauvaises interprétations de cette
valeur p en avril 2010 8 800 chercheurs
de par le monde ont publié une tribune
pour appeler à changer les habitudes du
monde de la recherche sur ces
surinterprétation à propos de la
significativité il insiste pour rappeler
que ce chiffre ne mesurent pas les
chances que le phénomène existe il ne
mesure pas la taille du phénomène et
surtout il ne permet pas de décider si
on doit accepter ou rejeter le phénomène
cette idée de rejet de l'hypothèse nul
est à l'origine de beaucoup de confusion
même au sein des chercheurs les
statistiques sont un domaine très facile
a mal interprété
en attendant le citoyen standard pas
spécialiste comme moi tu dois être
sacrément prudent quand il dit que une
étude a montré que est encore plus
prudent lorsqu'il dit que toute la
science
merci à vous d'être aussi enthousiaste
sur les sujets autour de la méthode
scientifique
elle est certainement perfectible mais
tellement passionnante on en parle dans
les commentaires ou mieux sur le
discorde du vortex et si tu aimes le
café on voit des pousses amero ça au
moins c'est pas mauvais pour la santé